[Music]
yesterday I'm going to talk about the
future of currency and I'm gonna focus
mostly on cryptocurrency and blockchain
innovations one of the things that has
become interesting about talking about
this subject over time is that when I
first started speaking about it a
general audience would know almost
nothing today almost everyone has an
opinion about it which in some ways
makes it harder to start a conversation
since people are coming from very
different perspectives but today I'm
gonna sort of start at the beginning
but hopefully even for those of you in
the audience who are experts some of the
perspectives will get you thinking and
then we'll have a discussion starting
around 10:15 where we can take it in all
sorts of different directions so I got
interested in in cryptocurrency and
blockchain back in 2012 in 2013 I had
some computer science colleagues who
were working on it and then I also went
to various conferences tech conferences
where a lot of people in Silicon Valley
were starting to get interested in it
and you might hear someone say at one of
these sort of tech elite conferences
something like I was you know employee
number you know X double digits at
Google and I've now put you know 20% of
my wealth into Bitcoin this is this
great thing and my first reaction to
that was you guys are bad people you're
doing a Ponzi scheme how could you be
doing this this is not this is not good
but when I started digging into it and
really understanding it I got very
excited about the technology and its
potential since then I joined as an
advisor for ripple and I'll talk a
little bit as I go through about what
made me initially excited about ripple
and then join the board a year later but
before their series a and now ripple is
is one of the more successful companies
in this space which is really great and
that was founded co-founded by Chris
Larson who's
GSB alum as well so we've it's a so we
have had a really exciting time with
this space I and now I'm teaching a
class to the MBAs we were way over
enrolled and had about a hundred people
in the in the spring on this topic the
students here at Stanford are also very
excited about this space there's a sort
of an informal organization of students
that has about 700 people on their
mailing list so it's a really really
exciting area at the same time there's a
pretty big gap between sort of how many
student projects come in from MBAs to
engineers what they're all excited about
what to do with blockchain versus the
reality of you know what's actually
going into commercial production so I'll
say it's sometimes hard for me to even
to communicate my schizophrenia on this
topic which on the one hand is like
fascination and research and teaching
and leadership in the area and on the
other hand for any particular person
who's thinking about investing in a
company or in a currency there's still a
lot of skepticism that needs to be you
know kept kept into place so hopefully
we'll get the the the balanced view of
all of these things as we go through so
first of all I want to talk about it's
actually even using the words it's kind
of tricky in this area whether you talk
about cryptocurrency whether you talk
about blockchain actually none of the
words are really perfect for describing
what's going on so it's more about like
the thing that you're doing rather than
the terminology but there's really you
know a bunch of different ways to think
about what cryptocurrency is and one
reason that can actually be difficult to
have a conversation around it is that
everyone has a different idea in their
head and people start talking across
purposes so you know one one thing to
think about with cryptocurrency is it's
a way to store value it's sort of like
digital gold and now that's there's a
group of people who are very strong on
that use case and that that's a use case
that's happening especially you know if
you're a billionaire and you've sort of
diversified at all of these different
assets and you have your you know your
house in New Zealand and you have your
bunker you know why not you know put ten
percent of your assets into something
like Bitcoin and then the
keys are actually stored in bunkers
around the world and it helps you kind
of protect yourself but it's actually
you know it's actually sort of a
cumbersome way for a typical person to
try to hedge book for security reasons
and also just for for there's there's a
lot of technological impediments as an
asset class I'll probably won't have
time to show you too much on those
statistics but it is kind of an
interesting asset class because it's
it's not that correlated with other
traditional asset classes and so it's
even in the short term when you're not
worrying about the world blowing up in
some way you know it does provide sort
of a differentiated type of asset the
thing that sort of got me most
interested in the beginning is the idea
that it can be used as a payment system
now it's going to turn out that it's
pretty hard to make a new payment system
and if you're if you're in an economy
that has a pretty well-functioning
payment system it's really not going to
provide a lot of benefit you know I've
had students come into my office for you
know 15 years saying how they're gonna
compete with the credit cards that's
just actually a very hard thing to do
the economics of credit cards are pretty
hard to enter it's not about the
technology so you could say the
technology's archaic but you know the
it's actually the economics that make it
a difficult place to enter not the
technological improvements but what one
of the places where things are really
broken are international payments and so
that's a place where we're seeing
adoption as well as real economic value
from from cryptocurrencies and then the
final thing which is really where
actually most of the of the sort of
engineering teams are really working is
that you know it's a really a platform a
technology platform so especially
something like aetherium is is built as
a sort of a software development system
and I'll talk a little bit more about
how people are using that but it's
really like a technology that's it's a
building block for some other kind of
service some way to a database some way
to store information and that's where a
lots going on if anybody's interested
more in these application areas because
we can we have relatively short time
today
GSP lecture Doug Galen has written
recently a very nice paper that surveyed
all of the blockchain for good
initiatives and it talks about in depth
about where the startups are which ones
are close to actually you know having a
working product and so on and
interestingly the biggest category he
finds is healthcare and not finance and
it's basically cuz there's a lot of
businesses coming up with databases for
health information that are where people
can actually control other people's
access to their own health information
and that information is stored in a
database that they can selectively grant
access to there's a lot of variants on
that idea but that's one of the more
popular ideas and there's a lot of these
companies because every country in the
world has their own system and health
data is sort of something that's kind of
both valuable and somewhat broken in in
most economies so already hopefully just
as this intro we can think about there's
not just one thing here there's lots of
things so I'll try to build up from the
very beginning I'm gonna focus on the
currency aspect both that's sort of the
title of the top but also I think it's
the one that's the easiest to start
wrapping your heads around and once
you've got those basics it you can then
think more about these broader
applications one other comment though
about this whole application area is
that you know I see I've seen you know
hundreds of projects come across my desk
I feel like a lot of those conversations
where there where it's my advice or
where the students come back later and
tell me where they ended up there's a
mem on Twitter that says you look one of
these little flowcharts that says do you
need a blockchain until you're expecting
like a whole bunch of different things
and then there's just one arrow down and
it says no and it's some level like
that's a that's a pretty good
approximation for what a typical a
project comes up at nonetheless you know
I think there's still incredibly
interesting to think about where where
we are going to go and it just says that
you know when somebody gives you a shiny
new hammer
you don't necessarily immediate
we find the nails and there's a lot of
hammers looking for nails but over time
as our understandings of these
technologies emerge then when use cases
emerge that do fit it'll be more like
here's my problem
and oh there's a technology that might
actually fit but but it's much harder to
start a business with a good business
idea and then fit the technology rather
than saying oh there's a shiny new
object let me start a business that
might where that technology might be
useful and I think that's sort of the
stage we're at and that's what really
came out of my cryptocurrency class and
the in the spring as well that most of
even the best VC's didn't really have a
lot of real solid examples going on ok
so now let's really spend some time
getting into what this thing is building
up from the beginning so here's a
picture of a ledger Ledger's have been
used for a very long time and you know
it's we actually sometimes your econ one
on one course you'll hear about like
early barter economies where like
somebody trades an orange for an apple
but actually that was never a super
common way to do business because it is
kind of hard to have an orange and an
apple at exactly the same time and so
you know through millennia people have
kept track of who has what and had some
sorts of ledger systems and they've been
everything from you know stones to Marx
on wood before we had paper you know to
keep track of ok you gave somebody you
gave something and then later on you
should get something back and so
Ledger's of course are a really a
fundamental way to understand understand
money as money is a way to make it
simpler than having a ledger because if
I just give you a dollar I don't have to
go look up on a ledger but it sort of
serves the same purpose you give me
something now I give you a dollar later
on you can use that dollar for something
else so Ledger's are old Ledger's are
powerful it really is useful to have
Ledger's and the the problem is that
when we have gone to the digital economy
the cash which sort of made it simpler
than keeping track of a ledger doesn't
work in the digital world I can't beam
you a dollar and in ours in our
financial systems haven't really caught
up to be fully digital so that we can
money sort of as easily as we move in
our information so what is it I mean I'm
gonna focus on Bitcoin just as sort of
the the kind of biggest and and first
big innovator here so what bitcoin is
that its core is just a big ledger it's
a big spreadsheet okay so Wow how could
people be so excited about a big
spreadsheet but that is what it is a big
spreadsheet so imagine you know be
convenient if you're trying to interact
with people digitally to keep track of
who has what suppose you're across
countries and it's sort of hard to
really you know move money you could
just have a big Google Doc big Google
spreadsheet and you know you could have
people only authorized to make entries
in the spreadsheet if they had a
password and we can put a little bit of
logic on top of that which might say
that you know your entry gets rejected
if you don't have another entry in the
spreadsheet so we can have a big
spreadsheet that says and forget about
how you the initial conditions just for
a moment we'll come back to that but
suppose the spreadsheet starts and says
I have a Bitcoin you have a Bitcoin
someone else has a Bitcoin then
essentially what you would want is I can
login if I have the right credentials
and say I I'm gonna make an entry that
says I give a Bitcoin to someone else
and we'll we'll reject that entry if I
don't have a Bitcoin but if I have a
Bitcoin and I logged in I can make an
entry that says I give it to someone
else
okay this would be a convenient thing to
do too if we if we didn't have weren't
all on the same banking system it would
be nice just to have a big spreadsheet
to keep track of who has what and that's
what bitcoin is that's all it is there's
a big spreadsheet if you if it says that
you have something and you have a
password you can log in and make another
entry that says you give it to someone
else that's really the only
functionality of this technology okay so
why would you be excited about that well
if you imagine that I was keeping you
know 50 billion dollars worth of stuff
on a big Google spreadsheet we might
have some security concerns okay and if
I said oh I'm gonna spin up a server in
my house on campus and you
I'm gonna keep the copy of the
spreadsheet on my server well I would be
like a magnet for you know attacks from
all over the world and of course I want
people to be able to access this so I
would have to sort of be open to the
Internet in some way which would create
a security nightmare so the idea of
Bitcoin is to just to get this this
product the product is a very simple
product which is just a spreadsheet
where people can from all over the world
make entries but I'm going to find a way
to make it secure okay and I'll come
back to the security that's of course
one of the really interesting parts but
for now let's just imagine we have this
product I'm gonna tell you more about
what you would do with the product and
then we'll come back to how it works
so just to kind of get a sense of
exactly what happens um
again there's a big spreadsheet and it's
gonna have addresses on it these are
synonymous addresses and in fact people
can have multiple addresses so if I have
an address that's mine the way the entry
that would come to me at first would be
somebody else sending me a Bitcoin and
making an entry on the ledger
then if the ledger says I have one and I
have my password what I would do is I
would sit at my computer login say you
know I want to make a new entry
authenticate the entry said the new
entry will be a Bitcoin goes from my
address to someone else's and so when I
say login what I mean is that I have the
credentials associated with that address
that allows me to make an entry and as
long as the the spreadsheet says that
yes this address received those coins in
the past it will accept the new entry to
send them to something someone else okay
so far this sounds kind of fun sort of
like training trading beanie babies or
something I have a beanie baby I sent
you a beanie baby something you send a
beanie baby to someone else of course
this only is useful if if there if it's
if there's some value and having these
entries on the ledger but I want to
point out that that value does not
derive from the ledger itself so we're
gonna be able to have markets where we
buy and sell entries on the spreadsheet
but those markets are just regular old
financial markets they're not part of
the basic protocol the the basic
protocol is just this spreadsheet so if
you want to see like how you access it
this is a screenshot of one of the early
wallets and in the early days of Bitcoin
most people would sort of manage their
own bitcoins and so the idea was that on
your own computer you would give a
little piece of software that would
actually download the entire history of
the ledger and then you would keep a
copy of it and actually you would join
the network by by participating by
keeping copies on your computer then the
software would look through the whole
ledger and just show you the things that
are associated with with you and so it
would simplify the whole history and say
ah these are the transactions associated
with addresses in your wallet and so you
would have you would put in a password
to access this and then you could do
things like send and receive and keep
track of contacts who would be addresses
and then you know make little
transactions either receiving or sending
okay um so when this actually goes out
there's a what is a blockchain it's
actually a sequence of you know little
little spreadsheets that are new and
additions to the ledger and so the block
it this is basically like all of it this
is what happens when you make a new
entry and so there's gonna be you know a
block and then it's gonna have a
transaction a fee a size the the from
and the - so that's basically all the
all the data in the protocol so now
let's start thinking about what what you
do with this and why it would even be
useful so I think the first thing I
thought about as an economist and those
of you from the finance sector will
presumably had the same initial reaction
is why would you introduce a new
currency like we have the eurozone to
avoid having lots of currencies any of
you that work in international
businesses know that like hedging
exchange rate risk is like a problem
it's not something that you would choose
to take on and generally for consumers
you wouldn't want them to take exchange
rate risk if they didn't need to so if
I'm why
he's gonna pay their rent in their taxes
and dollars you know you would generally
not want to hold another currency unless
you were using it as some quarter of
hedging strategy but it wouldn't be
something that you would you would
choose to do you wouldn't just take
volatility for no reason so the first
thing in sided okay this sounds really
cool I really like this technology for
keeping track of who has what but why do
it in in this thing called a Bitcoin why
not do it in dollars so I don't have a
big spreadsheet that says who has which
dollars and the key insight for that is
that actually we can't put dollars on a
spreadsheet directly so just just
imagine we have this spreadsheet
technology we could certainly put a
message on it that says you sent me a
dollar and I could make another message
that says I send you a dollar but what
would that really mean
because I didn't beam you a dollar like
there's a message on a spreadsheet that
says I sent you a dollar but I can't
actually send you a dollar on a
spreadsheet
I could have messages that say I promise
to give you a dollar but I can't
actually send a dollar on a spreadsheet
and that's really core to understanding
what could what could possibly be new
and different from a sort of currency or
asset perspective is that the definition
of a Bitcoin is the entry on the
spreadsheet so if I authenticate sending
a Bitcoin to you you have the Bitcoin
it's not an IOU for a Bitcoin it's not a
promise that to obey a contract and give
you a Bitcoin it's actually the Bitcoin
the entire definition of the asset is
the entry on a spreadsheet well if I put
a dollar on a spreadsheet because
dollars are not digital there I can't
actually send you a dollar literally on
this spreadsheet and of course those of
you from finance will will be familiar
that in some sense like when you're when
you're doing moving money
internationally you don't think about
dollars in Euros it actually those
dollars and euros live in a bank so
there's like Citibank dollars or JP
Morgan Dollars because if you were
moving around the world the way that you
go through dollars is to hold accounts
in a bank and
if you go from country to country you
might go from a smaller bank to Citibank
then Citibank would make an internal
ledger transfer themselves to a foreign
a foreign bank where they have an
account and then you would make another
transfer from the that foreign account
to a smaller Bank in that country and so
what we really have when we look
digitally our IOUs
when you open up Bank of America in the
morning and look at your your balance
you say oh well I have digital money
well you don't actually have digital
money you have an IOU from Bank of
America
Bank of America promises that if you
send a transfer they'll they'll make a
back end transfer but they actually
cannot promise you to do whatever you
want with it if you said I want to send
it to North Korea they would block it if
you sent a bunch of transactions for
nine thousand nine hundred ninety nine
dollars over and over again they would
block it okay and we've seen various
politicians get caught up with that type
of problem so you know they it's an IOU
that is subject to the rules and
regulations of a particular country and
so it can't actually be I I can hit Send
but I don't know that it the money will
go and in fact internationally about
five percent of wires fail the money
gets lost so you hit send but it doesn't
actually receive so any countries
companies that have a big supply chain
will have a whole little department of
like failed wire transfer chase or
Downers to deal with that problem so an
asset that is like this is of course
it's an interesting asset and it works
for most purposes but it is
fundamentally different from an asset
where when I make the entry on the
spreadsheet it's done okay it's good and
bad if you're a consumer and you type in
the wrong address in Bitcoin and you hit
send it is gone okay there is no 1-800
Bitcoin to reverse it you made the entry
the entry is permanent it is there it is
there forever if I if I sent a
transaction to Silk Road when I was a
college student and you know and
everybody knew what the Silk Road
address is that is also permanently on
the record okay so if somebody could
have so
that Bitcoin address with me then
forever you would know that I was
sending money to Silk Road when I was 21
so these things are permanent
irrevocable and actually on the Bitcoin
ledger public and in fact in some of my
research a few years ago I went in and
you know analyzed the blockchain and you
can see what people were doing and how
many people were gambling and how many
people are going to Silk Road you could
figure out what timezone they were in by
when they made the transactions and for
people who would ever like post it on
the web their Bitcoin address you could
figure out them and you could figure out
their friends and so on so it's actually
like a pretty in some ways a pretty
unsafe way for to do things because you
don't you usually value your financial
privacy and you have no recourse if you
type in the wrong number
also if you lose your password this is a
problem so in the early days there was a
big bang theory episode about this that
kind of formalized a bunch of my friends
experience I had lots of computer
science friends and early people toying
around with Bitcoin and you know 2011/12
the things were worth like a cent or you
know two cents or ten cents and then
they then they get up to you know a
dollar ten dollars you know then it in
last December they are eighteen thousand
dollars and you're like wait what
happened to that laptop what happened to
my password you know imagine like trying
to go back and find something that was
you know on a laptop in 2012 and there
were a lot of sad people because you can
look at the blockchain and you could say
oh those bitcoins are mine but you can
never get them back
you know so there are lots of people who
are like you know multimillionaires or
on paper but just can't get the coins so
it's an it so I have no effect those are
like all the negatives but of course
there is also some positives if you
think about in a business context
wouldn't it be nice sometimes to make a
transaction and like 10 minutes later
have it be done and there's no rollback
because then you could make another
transaction on top of that and another
one on top of that and you could have
computer programs do those transactions
and you would have the certainty that
they took place so that is a just a
different characteristic of these assets
that is really not cannot buy kind of
regulation cannot be provided by the
existing financial system for consumer
protection Annie mandala owner and all
that stuff will not allow a bank to
really offer that
so it's just different okay so now let's
talk a little bit about what you would
do with this and also that'll bring up
the idea of how these things are
actually valued so suppose I was my kid
was doing a Skype lesson actually one of
my kids now is taking Python over Skype
which is a very convenient thing to do
and you know you can get a teacher in
Silicon Valley it's hard to hire someone
to do anything for less than you know
$100 an hour but you know you can get
someone who lives somewhere else who's a
nice starving computer science student
who can teach Python to my child for a
much more reasonable price so you know
you do that you're doing some sort of
Skype lesson but suppose the teacher is
actually somewhere else or maybe you're
learning a language Japanese or Mandarin
and your tutor is in another country you
would like to pay them right away if
they're in another country if I wanted
to send them directly peer-to-peer or
wire transfer that might cost me 50 or
$60 which is large relative to the cost
of a lesson now platforms and so on will
try to make that easier for you but even
actually like Airbnb and uber and so on
are actually very upset about the state
of the current financial system because
it's so expensive for them to facilitate
these payments around the world so
they're actually some of the big movers
and pushing for improvements so if I
wanted to do this just peer-to-peer if
the recipient actually was understood
the way that Bitcoin works I could do
the following thing I would open up an
account on a on a company say like
coinbase or bitstamp
and these are companies they are not
part of Bitcoin they're just startup
companies and what they the service they
provide is a place where you can send
fiat currency and then do trading on
their system and so they just have
simple software that creates an order
book in every currency so I transfer in
my dollars using like an ACH transfer or
a wire transfer to get my dollars there
once my dollars are there then I could
just place a limit order or a market
order to say hey I want to buy a Bitcoin
and some people want to sell bitcoins
and they have nice little visualizations
in fact the software that for this is so
easy that I talked to a startup who set
up an exchange over a weekend you know
there's basically just off-the-shelf
software this is not rocket science to
do the really basic part of course the
security's another problem but the the
basic software is easy so then if I say
I want to buy some Bitcoin
what will happen is that that exchange
will then you know find the place where
the bids and asks cross make the
exchange and suddenly I'll be the owner
of a Bitcoin now what I can do with that
Bitcoin then is it at that point the
exchange is still holding the Bitcoin
themselves so they're still in custody
if the big if the exchange went out of
business right that minute I'd be out of
luck and that used to happen quite a bit
now there are some more you know
well-established companies with
governance and real engineers and things
like that so let's so one of these more
established ones I'm not real worried
about them going out of business in the
next five minutes so then I have the
Bitcoin and I can then send a transfer
to the Bitcoin the receivers Bitcoin
wallet and that can take place in about
10 minutes
so I say please send then their wallet
would receive that and then we could
just get off the Skype call they've been
paid we're done ok so it's a very nice
feature that you really cannot get
across borders anywhere else now what do
they do once they have it well they
could take the Bitcoin and buy a cup of
coffee or buy something online but if
they wanted to actually change it back
and be yen then they could transfer to
send the bitcoin onto an exchange and it
might be a Japanese exchange which would
receive the Bitcoin then they could
place an order to sell the Japanese
exchange would give them some yen and
then they could use the Japanese
internal country transfer systems to put
it into their bank account ok so this is
how you could do this and this stuff
happens all the time it's a very common
thing to do especially for these small
value transactions people use it to pay
programmers in Venezuela or all sorts of
other use cases now there's a few
problems with this first of all this is
kind of high friction this is not like
you know a simple consumer product
you're exposed to exchange rate
volatility along the way now that
exchange rate volatility might not much
be much within a day although like over
Christmas and I was caught up in this as
well because I was holding and was
trying to sell you know you you like the
price might move 5% or 10% in the course
of a day so you had to like be there at
your computer trying to get this stuff
done and not like be lazy about it but
generally in a given day it doesn't move
that much and you also have to worry
about these these exchanges going out of
business
one thing that doesn't matter is the
level of the exchange rate so this thing
works as well when Bitcoin is $100 a
Bitcoin as it is 18,000 a Bitcoin
because I'm just getting in and getting
out
so all those exchange rates will move in
concert I don't really care how high it
is what I do need is transaction volume
because in the early days you know when
it was not that popular you would the
spreads would be high and so you would
you would lose a lot on the bid-ask
spread today you know there might be
just even ripple which I'm talked about
later you know we were having lots of
four billion dollar days so four billion
dollars of transaction volume over the
holidays and then more recently it's
been about you know half a billion
dollars a day so that's more than a lot
of stocks and so that that means these
are actually like fairly liquid relative
to stocks and that's important for
making this work nonetheless you this is
really not a great consumer product and
the way this is would end up getting
mass marketed would be that a company
would do this for you and the consumer
really wouldn't see it so the consumer
would have enough and just say I want to
send money to Japan and the app would
implement this on the back end and there
are a number of products all over the
world that try to do that now there's a
few additional concepts that that become
interesting here it's like once you
understand all of that you realize that
actually these exchanges are kind of a
big source of friction and a source of
risk so what you might want to do
instead is have a decentralized exchange
where this is all done in software so
that all of the transactions go one
after the other and so v1 of this was
actually ripple into 2013 so this is
what their software looked like then
they built a sort of a new version of
Bitcoin that was similar in some ways in
different in others but one of the ways
that it was different is it actually
built into the protocol the ability to
have market makers make bids and asks as
well as a pathfinding algorithm that
would say if I want to send something to
Japan it's gonna find a sequence of
trades I can make to get me from the
dollars to the yen automatically so it's
the same thing as this previous picture
except for it all happens at once
through software so there might be a
market maker making a market between XRP
their currency in dollars there may be
another market maker making an offer
between yin and XRP they would plug into
an API and those mark
Maker's would commit that if someone
took their bids and offers then the the
the the the transaction would go through
they wouldn't have to manually approve
it would just be a standing offer and so
you could just take it and execute that
in three seconds so this is what they're
the the v1 of ripple did and that was
its differentiating thing and I thought
at the time this was really a big
improvement because I was generally
thinking consumers would not want to
hold a cryptocurrency themselves so if I
wanted to think about utility this would
be a better way so um this would and now
there's a there's a bunch of V twos of
this coming out now called decentralized
exchanges that on other protocols and
platforms are trying to implement this
idea what the interesting thing that
happened with ripple is that they went
out and tried to sell this to banks and
said hey banks you might want to use a
system like this to move money across
borders and some banks were interested
but actually a lot of banks said hey
we're a little worried about this
cryptocurrency thing it's got regulatory
risks and it's gonna take some time to
figure it out but we love this idea so
could you do this for us but without the
cryptocurrency and then you actually
realize that Wow yeah why didn't we do
this before like we should have done
this without the cryptocurrency before
and you might ask why don't we do it
today and the answer is you know not
about the technology it's about the we
all use Swift and we're all stuck and we
have software systems that are used to
an old way of doing things and we just
haven't advanced so my economist friends
say well couldn't we just fix that and
I'm like yeah they are that's what we're
doing so you know rippled introduced
then something called an inner ledger
protocol which basically takes this idea
of a decentralized exchange and it's a
protocol that basically will say if I
want to get money from one end to the
other there might be a bunch of
middlemen market makers and people who
have accounts and multiple banks I'm
gonna they're all going to make offers
onto this protocol and then if I want to
get money from A to B we're gonna have a
protocol that insures the money
instantly goes from A to B but it never
gets stuck in the middle and like that's
a really nice thing because in the
today's system you tend to have delays
and have things get stuck in the middle
so the bottom line of how this is
getting used is that banks are basically
plugging in and we have there's a
in the middle-east there's also a big
group in Asia a big group of Japanese
banks have have just joined it's a lot
of smaller countries or the early
adopters and they're setting up their
own network so they don't have to go
through Swift because Swift is you know
some are archaic and it also ten it
doesn't go slowly their messaging
doesn't work very well and then the
smaller countries also feel they're very
disadvantaged because it's sort of
everything is going through a few large
u.s. institutions so in terms of the
future of currency in some sense part of
the role of the US dollar has been to be
a hub currency in a hub-and-spoke system
but with these new technologies the
smaller countries don't have to go
through that hub anybody who flies an
airline through a hub knows that you pay
a higher price and it can be slow and
the airlines kind of exact monopoly
power over you when they have control a
hub and and the smaller banks and
countries feel the same way about their
relationship with the large US banks
that where they have to pay markups and
face delays as they go over that system
so their be able to basically create a
peer-to-peer network that allows them to
move money instantly among themselves
without having to go through that now a
set of those actually I'm in a set of
those those countries are also using the
cryptocurrency right now it's mostly
remittance providers so there's a
company called koala kazooing it u.s. to
Mexico and there's a Association of
fourteen hundred US credit unions that's
doing it to help the credit unions
access international markets and so it's
kind of coming up from the bottom from
the smaller players who aren't well
served alright so let me now see a
couple quick words about mining just so
that you won't walk away not
understanding how this is so this all
started with this anonymous white paper
Bitcoin a peer-to-peer electronic cash
system and basically what they wanted to
accomplish was a worldwide network of
what we call weekly identified parties
to reach consensus on the contents of
the ledger so you might ask why would
you want this and I think actually a lot
of us would still ask that if you were
using a commercial implementation but
let's just take for a second what they
what they wanted to accomplish was sort
of intellectually mind-boggling I'm
gonna we said before we've got these
copies of the ledger we want to
decentralize them but I've got to
provide security somehow so how are you
gonna do that and their idea was to
allow people to join the network when
you had no idea who they were no way to
know no way to verify anybody can join a
college kids people in any part of the
world you know can join this network and
can help keep track of what the truth is
okay if you're gonna ask that anybody in
the world can join and keep track of
what the truth is you're gonna have to
figure out some way to make it costly to
join and that is part of what what this
this this whole system does so the
Nakamoto consensus says that we can let
anybody in the world join and keep track
of the ledger but if they disagree we're
going to use majority voting to say
which one is the right one so if I can
join the network and say I'm keeping
copy of the ledger my temptation would
be to put another entry that says
everybody just gave all their bitcoins
to me that would be fun and if I can
keep a copy bludger why wouldn't I do
that well the answer is that everybody
has to vote majority rule over whether
that's the right thing and nobody else
would want to approve that transaction
so because I wouldn't have authorized it
I wouldn't have had wouldn't have
followed the rules to do that so it's
voting and you're gonna have majority
rule now the immediate thing you think
of was wait if it's voting
why don't I just set up a hundred
thousand computers and have them all
vote for me okay that's and that is in
fact possible now the way that you avoid
that is are a couple of things first of
all if I set up a hundred thousand
computers and made them all give the
money to me then the prices and the
markets might crash so I might not
really get anything out of that and that
is one of the part the key things like
keeping it secure it's actually an
economic incentive if I tried to vote
break the system by creating a lot of
computers and giving all the Bitcoin to
me I wouldn't be able to sell them
because nobody would want to buy them
because they've just broke the system so
it's really an economic incentive model
it's not a cryptographic breakthrough it
is economic incentives that's very
interesting about this the but the
second way that they've
this is they make it expensive to join
so you can't just join and and and
create the ledger you have to actually
pay a fee okay but the problem is we're
all over the world we just said we don't
have an international banking system
that really works particularly well and
you know these people might we don't
even know who they are so how could I
you know get money from them so I want
them to pay to join the network but I
don't have a great way to collect cash
from them so the solution is you have to
burn money to join the network that's
the solution now if I literally had you
burn cash you might worry about how do I
know that you really burn the cash I
could doctor a video of me Vernon cash
and say hey I'm burning cash let me join
the network but that might mean that
might be hard to verify so they had to
figure out a way to burn cash to join
the network in a way you could tell
unambiguously that you burn the cash
okay so what's the solution to that they
set up this very hard math problem
that's using cryptography basically
we're the to solve the math problem the
only way you can solve it is to keep
guessing so every 10 minutes this system
is going to pose a question and then all
around the world people guess the answer
to it and so the way the and so you can
then use electricity and computing power
to keep generating guesses and guesses
and guesses and guesses and the only way
you'd ever get a right answer is if on
average is it if you burned a lot of
energy so the the barrier to entry the
analog of burning money is to burn
electricity and the way it's credible is
that I only reward you if you actually
solve the problem and on average you can
only do that if you burn a lot of
electricity so that is the system
bunch of people burning money all over
the world for the right to vote and
which is the right system but I just
wanted really emphasize that is an
economic breakthrough not actually a
cryptography breakthrough and then what
have what happened over time is that
actually it convento knee thing they're
good at is to solve these problems just
for bitcoins there's a whole industry
developing chips just for Bitcoin then
there are their server farms that are
now very you know streamlined and
efficient that buy these chips make the
server
and then solve these math problems and
try to get the rewards so it's actually
like a very the people respondents their
economic incentives to create mining
farms very quickly and it's a bit of an
arms race because you actually can't be
profitable at it unless you're using
cheap energy and the latest chips
otherwise you burn more energy than the
rewards that you get so now we have a
distributed ledger with a bunch of
people burning money all keeping copies
of it and we've achieved the security we
were looking for now it's turned out
because of the economics there's been a
lot of concentration in that like you
can diseconomies of scale so it's better
to be a big network and so we do
actually have more concentration and
people still worry about the control of
a small number of groups and in addition
this money burning has really gotten
quite expensive so it didn't seem like a
big deal when you were sort of a bunch
of people playing around with a science
project but right now Bitcoin consensus
cost about $10,000 per minute and
accounts for about 0.1% of world energy
consumption so it's actually very
expensive to burn that energy and then
people are out there thinking about
alternatives are there ways to get all
these benefits without having to burn so
much money it ranges from trying to do
something productive with your
electricity instead of solving this
useless math problem to other things
like proof of stake where you get to
vote if you have some commitment to the
ecosystem and and then a third solution
is to actually not just let anybody join
so and that sort of thing I'm burning
point one percent of US energy
consumption just because I wanted to
have the feature that anybody in the
world could join anonymously
maybe if I restricted energy a little an
entry a little bit I wouldn't have to do
that so finally I'll just mention that
one of the cool things you can do with
Bitcoin is to create software that moves
this money so in a typical escrow system
for buying a house you would have a
central party who keeps everything
checks if certain conditions are met and
distributes the funds while smart escrow
is like is a simple example of a smart
contract it's a piece of software that
can hold on to funds check the state of
the world was there a hurricane did the
stock price go up did something else
change and as a result of that in a
state contingent way distribute the
assets so I could head your risk around
the world I could place a bet with
anybody without having to trust them
know them or pay a bank to
there's a middleman just by running up a
piece of software and that software is
available at scale there are platforms
for creating those software so people
can create these types of contracts and
and and allow new things to happen and
that's one of the big areas of
innovation so I think I will stop here
and open up for questions and yeah we
can take it any direction there's lots
of places we haven't gone yet about the
value of the currency anything else so
let's open up to questions now and then
we got mics coming around so up here yes
can you talk a little bit about the
future of energy consumption there's all
this data mining yes so I I mean I think
it's a big problem and it's some level
you know if you if you said oh is a
country gonna try to use Bitcoin for
their national currency or are we really
gonna see something like you used to use
at scale I think that the this energy
consumption money burning thing is just
a fatal defect from having it really get
big as a transaction mechanism and so
when you talk to countries some
countries are thinking about getting rid
of cash entirely like England is
advanced in that some of the
Scandinavian countries are thinking
about that and they have thought about
can we use this technology to have a
fiat currency but but just not have cash
have it be purely digital but none of
them are seriously thinking about you
know I'm gonna have this kind of proof
of work energy burning thing to run a
national system they would instead sort
of limit entry like manually you would
have a distributed system but you kind
of have to have permission to join and
then you don't have to burn the money in
the same kind of way yeah so my
understanding from the regulatory
standpoint is the central banks will
tolerate this as long as it's marginal
but the idea that you can move very
large sums of money which ultimately is
fiat money across borders is not
something they're going to tolerate when
it gets to scale so it's a great
question so there's I think it's really
important to separate two use cases so
one is the consumer to you consumer use
case like over Skype
and that I think is very threatening as
to high inflation countries that have a
lot of capital controls and I basically
I would like go short any country that
is dependent on capital controls by the
way cuz you can't put this genie back in
the bottle like this technology is out
there and there are privacy-preserving
versions of it so essentially you just
cannot keep your capital in your country
at scale in the future but that the
concern about that is one reason they
would clamp down of course other things
are sort of any money laundering and so
on now the business this is one reason
I'm more interested in the
business-to-business case which is sort
of what ripple is doing because in that
case nothing changes in terms of the
regulatory framework the consumer never
touches it so consumer is still going
through the same financial institutions
and the financial institutions are just
doing it on the back end and for that
use case actually the central banks of
smaller countries are incredibly
enthusiastic they're actually pushing
their countries forward because it just
as a matter of national policy having
your entire country dependent on you
know paying markups to Citibank is a bad
thing and you know you also sub subject
to regulatory risk that the US can
change regulations which can make it
harder for certain countries to move
money where they want to move that so
from that perspective getting this sort
of peer-to-peer kind of regional
networks the central banks are actually
incredibly enthusiastic what they want I
think is they don't there's our happy to
go to a new technology they just want to
make sure that that they still have the
normal gateways and so that I think is a
much more promising Avenue nonetheless
they're still thinking more about the
technological solution and only some of
them have really embraced scripto
currency as as a conduit as a hub
currency so in your opinion which
cryptocurrency has actually tried to
solve the flaws of Bitcoin or which is
the most advanced that's part one part
two is that is there a better model
available than Bernie energy that can
cure a fit of that of the fundamental
flaw in all these mechanisms so this is
a very deep question and you
could read you know thousands of pages
on Reddit of people arguing about this
so I I will I will say a few kind of
comments but I cannot claim to have all
the answers
so when I first started talking about
alternative cryptocurrencies in say 2013
and I was involved with ripple very
early there was a whole set of people
including some of our famous tech
leaders in Silicon Valley who would
stand up and say you know scale
economies you know the best thing
doesn't always win Bitcoin was first
Bitcoin Bitcoin Bitcoin everything is
gonna be Bitcoin these other things are
all gonna die I would stand up and
quietly raise my head and say well you
know if you're thinking about enterprise
software it's not all just like the
Betamax and VHS and you know Netscape
versus ie in fact in enterprise software
you typically have a lot of different
vertical solutions serving different
parts of the market with different
combinations of features and so my
thought was that we will see different
systems for different purposes and in
fact that is sort of how that's evolved
so I don't think there's one size fits
all so ripple wants to move you know
hundreds of billions of dollars or
trillions of dollars between banks
internationally so they need a highly
scalable system that is and these
proof-of-work stuff is just a complete
non-starter so they have sort of in some
sense controlling who who keeps track of
the ledgers and they also have software
that allows you to just move things
without even touching the cryptocurrency
so you wouldn't even really call it a
cryptocurrency solution for that use
case that is what's taking off and the
other things are not taking off so much
for developers you know you might you
you might want a cryptocurrency that
actually has the ability more more
ability to write software embedded in
the protocol and so aetherium has gone a
lot in that direction in terms of making
it easy for people to build software on
top of aetherium so aetherium is almost
thinking of itself like an operating
system really and so that's good for
that there are coins that preserve
financial privacy so there are coins
that actually do everything that Bitcoin
does and there's still a big lecture but
nobody from the outside can look at it
and and reconstruct the network of who
sent what to whom if you're trying to
evade capital controls or do money
laundering that's your currency you know
that looks great
and of course consumers might have an
interest in financial privacy even if
they're doing legitimate things because
if they if you can see on the network
that you hold a lot of cryptocurrency
you're actually vulnerable to kidnapping
and all sorts of other things and you're
more vulnerable with crypto because the
money can move across borders so fast so
you can your risk of theft in a way that
you're not forced the money that's
stored in a bank so I would just say
that they're different and and I don't
think it's gonna be one-size-fits-all I
don't think there's gonna be a thousand
but there may be 15 or 10 that you know
actually each solve a different use case
better and the biggest problem right now
is we actually have very little product
market fit there's not there's hardly
any actual use cases where this thing is
really doing a great job so trying to
make it one size fits all it just makes
that problem harder rather than easier
but this is a very controversial thing
and if and there's a top it out there's
all these between Twitter bots that are
trying to make people buy and sell
currencies starting just like though in
the election you know we have these
twitter bots that in created division
and tried to make everybody hate each
other well the crypto space has all
these bots that try to make everybody
hate each other and troll each other so
it's really just kind of a Wild West in
terms of the conversation on that topic
we keep hearing about tokens all the
time these days where do tokens fit into
all of this well so I mean the the
Bitcoin is the token for that ecosystem
and you know XRP is the token for the XR
the ledger I think one of the ways
people are kind of like this I said you
have a token economy and since I'm
actually really a marketplace expert and
this crypto thing is a relatively new
thing but you know some I'm on the
boards of Lending Club and Expedia and
rover which are marketplaces so I've got
a lot of people coming into my office
pitching me these like marketplace
economies where the idea is that oh you
give your medical data then somebody's
gonna pay you in a token you hold the
token now you want to get other people
to join the system so your token will
get more valuable and then that will
grow or the tokens might also replace
like frequent flyer miles or other types
of ideas so there's all these ideas
about sort of businesses that are built
on top of block chains with tokens that
are specific to the business and then
there becomes a little economy and those
tokens and everybody wants to make it
grow and they're all invested in this
the business so you know in some level
that's how Bitcoin started so you can't
say that the idea doesn't make any sense
and it can make sense but the hard part
with all of those things is just getting
them started you know they all face a
chicken-and-egg problem and unless you
have a good business you know those
tokens are just nothing but it's a very
hot topic for entrepreneurs yeah I'm
still really confused about the whole
voting business when it comes to the all
the different Ledger's the different
versions I mean what actually happens if
my computer actually keeps a ledger and
a new transaction comes in how does my
computer either accept or reject that
transaction as a legitimate transaction
so if you are if there's this is kind of
confusing because they're sort of in the
equilibrium and out of equilibrium so
like when the system is working then
there's just software that you would run
and it would say here's a new batch of
transactions it would check a set of
rules so like was this person authorized
to make the transaction did they have
the Bitcoin and so on and so in that
state of the world the software just
checks a set of things and and then
accepts or rejects it so there's no
problem so what's what makes it more
confusing is if you think about some
sort of out of equilibrium behavior
which could take a whole bunch of
different forums but they all would have
the same idea of putting things on the
ledger that didn't follow the rules and
so that's the case that where you know
other people would say hey my my copy
doesn't look like your copy and if
they're following the rules they would
just say well I don't know what happened
that you must have made a mistake we're
gonna do the same thing as everybody
else I checked and I agree the he
checked and he agrees all good we just
keep going
so these attacks are the things that are
sort of could take a variety of
different forms could you speak a little
bit more about blockchain for good
specifically like v chain for vaccine
authentication or other healthcare
applications sure so and there's again a
whole variety of them a lot of them are
nascent I think one one idea that I
think does have legs is trying to follow
supply chains and
complex settings so if you're the Gates
Foundation and you're trying to move
money around Africa you know you give
the money and there's this whole leakage
along the way and a lot of stuff is in
digital and there's a lot of corruption
so it's hard to make sure it got where
it was going so one thing you can
imagine happening and it's certainly
been discussed is that some big
institution whether it's like the World
Bank or the Gates Foundation or someone
else it's really big could sort of force
their supply chain to track funds
through a distributed ledger and that
might be useful because the people
you're dealing with don't actually have
identities like you actually have to use
suppliers who you really can't verify
and the countries themselves don't have
good legal institutions and so on
so that's a good use of the blockchain
if it's a if it's just funds you could
just see them going from one person the
other and and they would be dispersed
you know split up as you go along so a
big block grant here and then it's
dispersed and dispersed and dispersed
but you would have a ledger that keeps
track of that until the very end another
way that you can do that is with
physical goods and there you get into
this challenge of how do you keep track
of this physical good but the really
simple version of the idea is there's
some kind of barcode that's really
embedded in the good that you can't take
out easily and you scan it at the
beginning and then as it moves along
it's scanned again and every time it
moves from Party to party
that triggers funds being released as
well as a record of what happened and
again we already have IT systems to do
that today it works great inside a firm
but it doesn't work so well if you're
going across countries in Africa or
someplace that doesn't have good systems
so those are some of the applications
that might get donors to give more money
or make things more efficient and then
other types of things I mean the
vaccines thank you maybe there's there's
a counterfeit vaccines so you might want
to scan the vaccine at the factory and
see that this is on authentic vaccine
and then at the end you could tell that
it was real and people have also talked
about it for just counterfeit luxury
goods in China no there's been versions
of those businesses that don't involve
blockchains and when you really dig into
it you might say really neat I don't
need the full Bitcoin I just need a
database I just need a database of
access so the questions still arise of
like what's the best way to do that
what's the very best technological
system to manage us
by chain do you have any estimates of
how much illicit versus legal
transactions are going on in the
cryptocurrency space yeah so in the
various people have analyzed this at
various points in time so my own
analysis is a bit dated now cuz it was
mostly 2015 and 2016 so by far the
biggest thing that people are doing with
these things is day trading and like
holding them so I was actually excited
to look at all the stuff people were
doing but most people are just not doing
anything you know they bought them they
held them and then the price went up and
they sold them or they're just trading
them a lot so most of the volume is just
on and off exchanges and they're not
actually doing all these great things
that we imagined they would do the now
of course all that liquidity can make it
cheaper for someone to build a real
business and so like the u.s. to Mexico
the fact that there's all these day
traders it makes it really cheap for a
remittance provider to get in and out of
say XRP going to Mexico the fact that
there's a lot of trading volume but
that's the main thing they're doing and
then among the things where you could
identify what they were doing yes Silk
Road was big gambling was big you know
but in some sense that's just sort of
like in the early days there's just not
really much to do with it you know one
of you know you're you want to just have
fun so you're just kind of doing things
for fun you're buying coffee cuz it's
cool not because you really need to so
it's hard to kind of draw inferences
from from that very nascent time period
so I think though you know go so right
now really like no people aren't using
it at scale period but though these
illicit use cases are won in use case
that's where there's not a better
alternative today and that's partly why
that's like an actual use case thanks so
much everybody for coming
[Applause]
[Music]
you